y dársela".
Mi padre tiene demencia del lóbulo frontotemporal o FTD.
Es una enfermedad confusa que afecta a personas entre 50 y 60 años.
Puede cambiar completamente la personalidad de alguien,
haciéndole paranoico e incluso violento.
Mi padre ha estado enfermo durante una década,
pero hace tres años se puso realmente enfermo,
y tuvimos que sacarlo de su casa...
la casa en la que crecí,
la casa que él construyó con sus propias manos.
Mi encantador y musculoso padre, que canta con voz de falsete,
tuvo que trasladarse a un centro de atención las 24 horas
cuando solo tenía 65 años.
Al principio mi madre, mis hermanas y yo cometimos el error
de ponerle en una residencia regular.
Era realmente bonita;
tenía moqueta y clases de arte por las tardes
y había una perra llamada Diane.
Pero entonces recibí una llamada.
"Srta. Malone, hemos arrestado a su padre".
"¿Qué?"
"Bueno, él ha amenazado a todos con los cuchillos.
Y ha arrancado las cortinas de las paredes,
y ha intentado lanzar las plantas por la ventana.
Y, bueno, él ha tirado a todas las ancianas de sus sillas de ruedas".
"¿A todas las ancianas?"
(Risas)
"Menudo vaquero".
Después de expulsado de allí,
fuimos probando entre varios centros estatales
hasta encontrar un centro de tratamiento específico para personas con demencia.
Al principio, más o menos, le gustaba,
pero con el tiempo su salud empeoró,
y un día al entrar
me lo encontré sentado ovillado en el suelo con un mono...
del tipo que tienen la cremallera en la espalda.
Lo observé durante una hora mientras trataba de liberarse,
buscando una forma de quitarse esa cosa.
Y se supone que debe de ser práctico,
pero para mí era como una camisa de fuerza.
Y entonces hui.
Le abandoné allí.
Me senté en mi furgoneta -- su antiguo furgoneta --
me hice una bola,
con este profundo y gutural llanto que surgía del fondo de mi estomago.
Sencillamente no podía creer que mi padre,
el Adonis de mi juventud,
mi queridísimo amigo,
pudiese creer que este tipo de vida mereciese la pena ser vivida.
Estamos programados para priorizar la productividad.
Así que cuando una persona -- un Adonis en este caso --
ya no es productivo de la manera que se espera de él,
de la forma en la que él mismo espera ser,
¿qué valor tiene esa vida?
Ese día en la furgoneta,
todo en lo que podía pensar era que mi padre estaba siendo torturado
y que su cuerpo era la cárcel para esa tortura.
Tengo que liberarlo de ese cuerpo.
Tengo que sacarlo de ese cuerpo; voy a matar a papá.
Llamé a mi hermana.
"Beth", dijo,
"no quieres vivir el resto de tu vida
sabiendo que has matado a tu padre.
Y probablemente te arrestarán,
porque él no puede absolverte.
Y tú ni siquiera sabes cómo comprar heroína".
(Risas)
Es cierto, no lo sé.
Lo cierto es que hablamos mucho sobre su muerte.
¿Cuándo ocurrirá? ¿Cómo será?
Pero desearía que hubiésemos hablado sobre la muerte cuando aún estábamos bien.
¿Cómo sería mi muerte ideal?
¿Cómo sería tu muerte ideal?
Pero mi familia no supo hacer eso.
Y mi hermana tenía razón.
No debía asesinar a mi padre con heroína,
pero tenía que sacarlo de ese cuerpo.
Así que fui a un psíquico.
Y después a un sacerdote, y luego a un grupo de apoyo,
y todos dijeron lo mismo:
a veces las personas aguantan cuando están preocupadas por los que aman.
Solo dile que está a salvo, y que está bien que se vaya cuando esté listo.
Así que fui a ver a papá.
Lo encontré acurrucado en el suelo con el mono.
Estaba mirando más allá de mí y solo mirando el suelo.
Le di una cerveza de jengibre
y simplemente empezamos a hablar sobre nada en particular,
pero mientras le hablaba, estornudó por la cerveza de jengibre.
Y ese estornudo le estremeció todo el cuerpo,
devolviéndole un poco a la vida.
Y simplemente siguió bebiendo, estornudando y volviendo,
una y otra y otra vez
hasta que paró.
Y escuché:
"Je, je, je, je, je, je,
je, je, je, je, je, je...
esto es tan fabuloso.
Esto es tan fabuloso".
Sus ojos estaban abiertos y me estaba mirando,
y dije: "¡Hola, papá!"
y él dijo: "Hiya, Beth".
Y abrí la boca para decírselo, ¿no?
"Papá, si quieres morir, puedes morir.
Nosotras estamos bien".
Pero al abrir la boca para decírselo,
todo lo que pude decir fue, "¡Papá!
Te echo de menos".
Y él respondió: "Bien, yo también te hecho de menos".
Y entonces simplemente me desmoroné porque soy un desastre.
Me desmoroné y me senté con él
porque por primera vez en mucho tiempo él parecía estar bien.
Y memoricé sus manos,
sintiéndome tan agradecida de que su espíritu siguiese unido a su cuerpo.
Y en ese momento me di cuenta
de que no era responsable de esta persona.
No soy su médico,
no soy su madre,
por supuesto no soy su Dios,
y puede que la mejor manera de ayudarle, a él y a mí,
era recuperar nuestros roles como padre e hija.
Y simplemente nos sentamos allí,
tranquilos y callados como siempre hemos hecho.
Nadie era productivo.
Ambos aún somos fuertes.
"Vale papá. Me tengo que ir,
pero te veré mañana".
"Vale", dijo.
"Oye,
esta hacienda está bastante bien".
Gracias.
(Aplausos)